you know you recently made headlines
talking about Taylor Swift and her false
feminism do you think her get that big
of a reaction
no because okay first of all I was asked
between the Kardashian and Taylor Swift
who I would choose and I basically
because I was at the DNC it was like
when I go green party on this because I
am NOT on either side I'm not taking
sides I'm not I'm not Kardashian I'm
mutual and then it was hilarious because
I said to because I was like literally
all I know about Taylor Swift is that
she's really close with AG one girl one
week and then they get into a huge fight
and then all of a sudden all I saw like
I think my fiancé's mom texted me and
was like what's your problem with Taylor
Swift and I was like what happened are
you okay
I was like what's going on then I
started seeing all of these fans were
like why do you have against Taylor Bowl
and I looked at all the headlines and
out of this entire political interview
that I did that was the one line that
they took and I was like how you didn't
mean any harm right oh my god what I
meant was I literally don't know
anything about Taylor Swift or the
Kardashians so please don't make me
choose sides somebody would you say
you're fans of both oh no I really don't
like I don't know about either one I
don't care about either one